Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing the narration in
narration number 19,
the narration of
one of the lesserk known companions of
the prophet sallall.aii Wasam.
[Silence]
Yes.
So
came to
asking him about the permissibility of
wiping over one's footwear
after relieving
oneself
whether number one or number two as they
say or defecating or urinating.
And he said to
and you were one of the companions of
the prophet Sam.
So I came all this way to ask you, have
you heard have did you ever hear him
mentioning anything about that? Meaning
the rulings regarding wiping over the
one's footwear
after relieving himself using the
restroom. He said,
[Silence]
He com he he taught us that if we
were traveling
that we were not to remove our footwear
to make wulu for three days along with
their nights.
Except if we were in a state of janaba,
so sexual impurity.
[Silence]
Yet he would teach us and command us to
wipe over our footwear in making and
performing mul from defecating or
urinating or sleeping.
This statement here, defecating or
urinating or sleeping
pretty much
mentions
the chief invalidators of wudoo.
If we were to say
what invalidates a person's woo what are
the things that if they occur or if a
person does them his or her woo will
become invalidated
there are
four things that will invalidate a
person's wuboo
everything else
it may be preferable to make woo or
encouraged to make wudoo. But these are
the things that will categorically
break a person's wudoo.
Number one
and number two, anything that comes out
of the two private parts.
Anything that passes through the
front or back private parts.
So the first two is anything that comes
out of the private parts. Anything.
Notice the wording. Anything.
Number three
is
number three is deep sleep
or unconsciousness
for any reason.
Deep sleep.
How deep is the sleep? so deep that a
person is unconscious,
right? Not light sleep, not a light
slumber.
There is a a level of sleep where a
person would maybe doze off or have the
beginnings of sleep, but if someone were
to walk in the room, even if they don't
make any noise, person would wake up or
notice. Or if there were a noise or
someone speaking, they would hear it.
This person who is in this state of
sleep
which is kind of a prelude to sleep.
This is referred to as a sinner, right?
A state of you know as a prelude to to
to sleep.
No,
then
this will not break a person's woo.
However, if they are asleep deep enough
that if something passed through their
private parts, they wouldn't feel it.
This is what breaks will do. This level
of sleep.
And as an extension of that, any loss of
consciousness, any loss of
consciousness, whether that be by way of
person falling unconscious or a person
drinking alcohol and becoming drunk
to where they've lost control or
consciousness.
or a person becoming so angry that
they lose their memory of what's going
on around them or what have you.
Anything of that nature, this will break
a person's will. Now notice that that is
an extension of what deep sleep which he
mentioned here.
The fourth thing and the final thing is
apostating from Islam.
If a person were to renounce Islam or do
something that will take him out of the
fold of Islam
then this will invalidate the person's
wudoo. If they repent from that which
enter back into Islam they would have to
remake their wudoo.
Everything else it is preferred that a
person make wudoo not necessarily what?
Obligated obligatory.
Now
many listening will say well what about
this and what about that? What about
vomiting for instance?
Vomiting is something that the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam did and then he
made wudoo. He didn't command that it be
done. It was a one-time occurrence. This
is where we learn that something is
preferable.
What about a person eating camel meat
for instance?
This is in the correct opinion
abregated.
It used to be a ruling in Islam that it
was obligatory and then it was later
abregated as was practiced by the four
Abu Bakr.
likewise
what about if a person touches the
opposite sex
whether with sexual arousal or without?
It may be preferred that a person make
wudoo. However, it does not invalidate a
person's wudoo. The statement of Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
[Silence]
to
the prophet sallallahu alaihi Wasam was
narrated to have kissed his wives
and went out to lead salah without her
making his woo. All right.
[Silence]
And that is what about if a person
touches his private parts or another
person's private parts. The correct
opinion is that a person has to have
sexual intention
and there's no barrier between his hand,
his skin and his private parts. It is
preferable. However, it is not
obligatory
to renew a person's woo for this. Why
are these things mentioned in the Sunnah
or or some of the companions mention
them or what have you? touching a woman
or touching a person's private own
private parts with with u with sexual
desire or why because these things are
because these things are likely to make
a person break his woo by way of sexual
arousals that something would come out
of his private parts pre-jaculate
and so forth. So these four things they
are the things that break a person's
will. Anything else is either preferred
that a person remake his wudoo or not
authentic or obligatory. If you memorize
these four things that
tells us here in this narration which is
an incredible narration because he
gathers them up all all of them. He says
when
those three things he mentions what
comes out of the private parts one and
two deep sleep or number three or number
four
that a person renounces
which is something that we mention
because it's mentioned in the books of
Alhamdulillah.
What is that?